The cynical attitude towards prayer is
something like asking God for favors,
and then of course the cynical analysis
of that is that if you ask God for
favors,
like he won't help you find your lost
wallet,
generally speaking,
no,
but that isn't.
If you're.
If you take a bit of a more
sophisticated approach to it,
you know what you're doing if you pray
is that you.
You formulate a question and you,
you wait for an answer like a prayer
might be,
okay,
I would like to do the best thing I
could with my life.
Now you have to open yourself up to
that.
That's to knock the door will open.
I would like to do the best thing with
my life.
What might that be?
Now you could say that you're thinking
when you say that are you are.
You could say that you're leaving
yourself open for revelation or an
intuition,
but you're communing with whatever it is
that enables you to receive wisdom and
you can attribute all of that to you or
you can attribute it to your brain,
I suppose,
but you're.
You're really communing with the
structure of the cosmos when you're,
when you're asking such a question and
especially if you do it properly and
it's really useful to do that and it's
really necessary because it orients you
properly.
So yeah,
the demise of prayer when prayer is
considered in a sophisticated manner,
which is,
do I commune with the better part of
myself,
let's say,
to determine how I should orient myself
in the world?
It's a catastrophic loss not to do that.